She has one of the earliest serial killers in recorded history.
The original sadomasochistic femme fatale.
She stands out as a shocking lesson in just down dangerous.
The sadistic,
demented,
powerful women can be the passing of the centuries has left us with an
incomplete picture of the true nature of our crimes,
but what we do know is truly stomach Channing and this week's biographics.
We pair into the depraved life of the blood count tests.
Elizabeth battery.
Okay.
The women we know is Elizabeth Bathory.
It was born as early a bit Bathory on August the seventh 1560 in nearby store in
the Kingdom of Hungary.
She was born into one of the most prominent families in central Europe.
As a result,
she was lavished with the very best education in classical upbringing.
During our formative years,
she learned to speak Hungarian,
Slovak,
Greek,
Latin,
and German.
Elizabeth was a child with severe health problems.
Historians have speculated that the fact that her parents were first cousins may
have contributed to how weak constitution she was an epileptic and as such was
prone to violence,
seizures.
It has been recorded that young Elizabeth was exposed to all sorts of horrific
atrocities during her formative years.
She has said to have begun laughing at the site of a man who's crime was
stealing being soon into the body of a horse.
She would also regularly witness the severe beatings of servants unlike other
young girls.
So Elizabeth was not offended by the violence that she saw.
In fact,
she seemed to be drawn to it.
By the age of 10 she had become a rather stunningly beautiful young lady.
It was then that she became engaged to a 15 year old Hungarian counts by the
name of fairing can Nadasky as was the custom sheet,
moved into our future husbands,
parents palace and received education.
Then running the estates that were under the control of her mother and yeah,
Legend has it that Elizabeth had an affair with a hasn't bought,
you know,
early teens and became pregnant.
It is said that she gave the child away secretly.
Meanwhile,
Aaron's is supposed to have discovered the affair,
had the peasants castrated and then thrown to a pack of wild dogs.
Whether this story is true or not,
it is clear that Elizabeth was active sexually.
She married Ferenc on May the eighth 1574 when she was 14 the wedding,
it was an extravagance of fair with four and a half thousand people in
attendance.
The party raged on for three days at the height of which parents gifted his wife
with a castle of her own.
It just so happens to be causal trash tits out,
one of the darkest,
most bleakly gothic castle in all of Hungary.
The car situations in the literal Carpathians and modern day Slovakia.
We're surrounded by a village and farmland.
It would come to be the scene of many of our most horrific crimes,
the marriage at United to powerful families,
and it made them the power couple of the day.
For the first few years,
Elizabeth was busy learning about and overseeing the many estates that she
controls.
Her husband was off fighting against the Ottomans.
He proved to be a great warrior,
noting himself.
The nickname of the black knight of Hungary is absolute brutality in the face of
the enemy.
Terrified his enemies since shocked his allies.
The Turks invaded Hungary in 1591 precipitating what had become known as the
long war,
which lasted from 1593 to 1606 the wall was to drag on severely depleting the
Hungarian economy.
However,
Elizabeth Bathory never felt the pinch because a husband kept showering her with
gifts from the Ottoman Empire.
In fact,
a couple of groups so wealthy that during this time they actually lends money,
do the Hungarian Habsburg Empire to keep the country a flute.
During the war years cashed it set was threatened by the tax.
Elizabeth had to defend her husband's estate since she did so effectively at
times.
Street also gave refuge to desperate peasants feeding and housing them.
Over the first few years of their marriage.
Elizabeth and foreigns didn't spend much time together.
When they did it said they bonded over their love of violence.
Torturing young servant girls see were under their charge.
Ferentz taught his teenage wife innovative methods of torture such as rolling up
pieces of oils,
paper,
placing it in between the toes of a seven girl and then setting it on fire.
It was also claims that he gave Elizabeth the Claude Glove for her to scratch up
the faces of disobedient girls.
There is no doubt that a husband introduced Elizabeth Duke or manner of
atrocity,
but there was another evil influence in 1601 the household was joined by a
strange woman by the name of Anna Doll Volya.
It was rumored that she was a witch.
What is undeniable though,
is that Elizabeth's personality underwear.
It's a dramatic change from the time the Darboy.
Yeah,
and to the household.
She became much more sadistic,
whereas the husband taught her to torture Anna towards her to kill.
Under the sinister to Jovana,
Elizabeth was responsible for the deaths of several of her servants.
Around this time,
the disappearances of the girls raised new eyebrows as peasants were completely
disposable at that time and place.
Any questions that were raised by family members were squelched quickly by
virtue of the huge power that the battery family hat Elizabeth was in all
practical tans untouchable.
She could torture and kill to our heart's delight.
Even the power of the family though could not prevent the reamers.
Local pastors became increasingly suspicious.
There's Elizabeth more frequently asked them to come to the castle to perform a
funeral rites for serving girls who had apparently died of cholera.
It is recorded that one priest,
after having attended too many funerals,
pulled her aside and said to her,
your grace should not have acted so because it offends the Lord and we will be
punished if we do not complain to you and criticize your grace,
and in order to find my words aren't true,
we need only exume the body and you will find that the marks identify the way in
which death occurred.
Elizabeth was outraged that the priest would deck.
He was there in this Nana.
She threatens that she had powerful relatives.
He would not tolerate such talk.
She then stormed out of the charge,
leaving it for her husband to smooth things over with the priest together.
The murderous couple had five known children with the youngest being born in
1598 around 60 no one Elizabeth's husband ferrets became unwell.
We don't know the specific nature of his condition,
but it led to paralysis.
If the legs,
he died in 1604 bringing their 29 year marriage to an ends at the time of her
husband's death.
Elisabeth was 44 years of age.
The loss of her husband cost another noticeable change,
and Elizabeth Sevens notice that she became even more sadistic.
The stress of having to take the reigns of an extensive Ambar was no doubt a
contributing factor.
It appears that she now transformed our pension for sadism from a hobby into a
full time preoccupation,
specifically Eby torture and murder of young women with almost 407 girls savor
the banks with our vast remains.
Elizabeth had no shortage of victims,
of course,
killing our staff.
It was a bit of a hassle as him and that she had to replace them.
So she increasingly began to lure girls from the villages surrounding our
castles.
When she had had her fill of torturing these unfortunates,
they would be flying over the castle walls to be ripped to pieces by wolves.
Elizabeth built up a loyal team of sycophancy facilitated have murderous
actions.
I know Delvoye.
Yeah.
Was her main accomplice also brought into these statistics cycle?
Was the nurse who looked after the children,
a woman by the name of a year and a Joe.
There was also a friend of hers involved by the name of [inaudible].
There was also a washer woman by the name of Katelyn,
the most sinister of the helpers,
Anna and darker,
who would try to outdo each other and inflicting pain on their victims.
The youngest of the murderous clan was a disfigured team by the name of fit
Skyrim.
The typical progression of a seven girl into this horror would begin with a
simple mistake and the performance of her duties.
This could be as menial as missing a stitch,
the counts as if she was present with fixing evil,
stare on the girl,
yell at her,
and then begin snapping her arounds.
Elizabeth,
the device,
all manner of creative punishments to go with specific misdemeanors and eagles
who made a mistake in any kind of sewing would be stabbed repeatedly with it.
Long sewing needles.
Usually girls would be stripped naked before they were tortured.
Elizabeth reveled in inflicting psychological torture on the victims after
sticking to needles into the fingers of a girl.
She would comment,
if it hurts the whore,
she can pull it out.
The girl would naturally take,
this is permission to pull the needle out.
But when she did,
Elizabeth would pull out a knife and cut the finger off.
She was also known to have at least one occasion bitten a chunk of flesh from
the face of one of her victims.
Services would be lucky to get away with a lost finger or two.
More often than not,
the blood lust within the deprived heart of the Countess was unable to be
quelled.
The girls would be dragged off to a torture chamber where Elizabeth employee to
torture squad to carry out much of her daddy work.
All manner of implements were made you soft cause the most gruesome afflictions
imaginable.
Pins says we used to rip flesh insides were torn out and there there've even
been reports that cannibalism was enforced on some of the girls.
We know certain details of what took place in the torture chambers of the
battery castles because of investigation and trial transcripts that occurred
when face eventually caught up with Elizabeth Bathory in our accomplices.
However,
over the centuries the legends took over and many of the crimes attributed to
her.
Oh yeah.
Fiction.
Perhaps the most pervasive belief is that she had blood drained from virgins and
would bathe in us in order to preserve her youthful beauty.
This story is almost certainly,
I'm sure you've not one of these seven girls who've testified against bathroom.
He mentioned anything to do with the practice rather accounts after accounts
mentions that the floors of the torture chambers were covered in blood,
which they would then have to clean up.
The counters showed absolutely no interest in preserving the blood as part of
some narcissistic beauty regime by 1609 the rumors of what we're taking place at
the battery castles were rife,
but there was nothing the law could do to put a stop to it.
At that time,
peasants were unable to bring charges against nobles.
Some parents even looked at the demented counters as a source of ready revenue
selling their children to have for a lump sum on the face of it,
the trade was made to provide seven duties,
but if the child was to die of cholera,
what of it Elizabeth?
Appetite for blood was insatiable.
The bodies were piling up at such a rate that how group of enablers web running
out of places to bury them.
Many of the girls were placed in shallow graves and the costs or courtyards,
and some of them were dug up by hungry dogs by the beginning of 1,609 and this
is what's closest confidant and adopt.
Valia died of a stroke around this same time,
Huh?
Debts began to mounts with all of the children grown and married.
The counters fell into a spiral of loneliness and depression.
For some reason,
Elizabeth decided that she needed to find a better class of victim.
We don't really know why,
but the general belief is that a lady steward as the major rover who many
believe to be or which convinced her that if she took the lives of noble girls
how financial fortunes with turn arounds or it may simply have been that she was
running out of peasant victims.
Whatever the reason for the change it led to Elizabeth to the decision to open a
finishing school for young women.
It would be the perfect cover for her to continue her torture us ways with a
higher class of victim.
At the same time,
the attendance fees that the parents of the girls paid would infuse some much
needed funds into the battery coffers.
Bye Now as appeared that Elizabeth is insatiable need to kill the young girls
and led to the depths of insanity.
It's certainly clouded our reasoning.
It was obvious that the aristocratic parents of teenage girls who suddenly
disappeared would move heaven and earth to get to the bottom of what had
happened to their pride and joy,
but none of that mattered to Elizabeth.
All she saw was a ready supply of nubile young bodies.
Inevitably the body counts began adding up and the parents came calling
Elizabeth May dumped the bizarrest of excuses.
One of the girls had gone crazy and killed the other girls before committing
suicide,
but no one was convinced.
Some parents appeal to the King Mathius the second and he decided to undertake
an investigation.
The official Raul investigation was put into the hands of the king's highest
ranking representative [inaudible].
This man happened to be one of Elizabeth's dead husband's closest associates on
his deathbed friends that even asked us to look out for his wife.
However,
there's his loyalty to the king was stronger than that of his old friend.
Still,
he treated Elizabeth with a level of respect that she would not have otherwise
have received that.
As I began to interview witnesses,
he soon had dozens of people that you testified to.
The counters is depraved ways.
Seven zoo,
it managed to get out of the cost of their lives.
Spoke of seeing blood drenched wools,
hearing terrible screams and noticing the ever growing readymade cemetery in the
castle courtyard.
However,
none of the people that Thursday spoke to you was an actual eye witness of the
torture.
Thursday you became convinced of Elizabeth skills.
However,
he felt terrible about the pledge that he had made to his dying friends that he
would account for his widow.
He decided to write,
do Elizabeth's relatives and ask for advice.
A secret agreement was reached by which the as it would be able to complete his
investigation,
but Elizabeth would never be brought to trial.
She would go direct need to prison without the embarrassment and the family that
a public trial would bring.
It's interesting to note that none of batteries,
relatives argued that she was innocent by December of 16,
10,
Thursday,
believed that he had enough evidence to arrest Elizabeth,
but he wanted to make absolutely sure.
Therefore,
he had himself in the king,
invited to dine at Battery Castle and Elizabeth was forensically nervous,
but she tried to act.
The gracious hostess things went well until she saved the men.
Uh,
post dinner dessert,
a cake on first divide.
The men began to feel unwell,
convinced that the contest had tried to poison them.
They may just be the accent.
On New Year's Eve,
16,
10,
Thursday returned with a contingent of armed guards.
They had outside the castle gates and wait it before a long Elizabeth and our
lady Stewart as the major river came out to Costa Protective,
spelled designed to protect the countess and bringing about the death of
investigator.
Thursday.
Thursday one is men listens to the women's incantations.
When the two went inside,
the investigators crept towards the is entranceway.
They immediately noticed the mutilated body of a young girl and near the doorway
to more were found just inside.
They then heard the sounds of screaming,
which led them to the torture chamber.
It was there that they discovered Elizabeth's murder team harder at work.
It is unclear whether the Thursday actually caught Elizabeth in the act of
torture.
However,
he was now convinced if that guilt,
the contest was found and taken into custody.
She immediately claimed their innocence,
blaming everything on her servants.
Those,
uh,
wasn't moved.
However,
and see through Elizabeth into her own dungeon.
In the end,
306 people testified against Elizabeth.
Even the members of her murder grew turned against a incriminating themselves.
In the process.
The total reported murder counts varies between 80 and 650 batteries.
Accomplices were put on trial in January of 1611 scores of witnesses and even
some surviving victims took to the witness stands.
The judges is also examined some of the cadavers that had been taken from the
battery consuls death sentences were passed down to I own a Joe Dorko and Fisco.
Prior to their executions I own a Jo Anne Dorko were given that own form of
torture.
Their fingers were torn out by iron tongs before they were put to death and then
tossed on a bonfire.
FISCO was spared this torture due to his youth.
Instead it was beheaded and then burns.
Catelynn was the only one who was not put to death.
She had been the most softhearted of the bunch on several occasions.
She herself had been beaten for sneaking food in for the victims.
She was sentenced to life imprisonment.
That was,
I kept his word to Elizabeth and she was never put on trial.
She was convicted and sentenced to life imprisonment in our own castle.
A confined to one of the dungeons which had been the scene of some of her
atrocities are only visitors,
were priests and the man who had put him behind boss.
That was like the Kyries reported that she was unrepentant and crazed with rage.
None of the priests was able to get it to acknowledge the severity of our crimes
and she continued to insist that it was a assistance.
Who are the real criminals are priests challenge tower as to why she didn't
order them to stop.
She said that she had been afraid of them.
Elizabeth reserve the greatest animosity for Thursday.
At one point when he came to see her,
she began to subjects him to an awful harangue at which points and to Jack did.
You are in the last months of your life.
You do not deserve to breathe the air on the earth or see the light of the Lord.
You shall disappear from this world and never really it again as the shadows and
develop you.
May you find time to repent,
you'll be steal life.
Elizabeth Bathory complained to a guard that she had cold hands on October the
21st 1614 he told us to go lie down and tried to get some sleep.
She did,
and she never woke up.
Her body was buried in the cemetery at [inaudible],
but it said that it didn't remain there long due to local uproar at the outrage
of having such a murderous buried in their midst.
The body was supposedly exhumed and taken to the battery family,
Krebs.
However,
when the crypt was opened in 1995 the corpse of Hungary's most infamous
murderous was nowhere to be seen.
So I'm not going to ask if he enjoyed the video,
but I do hope you found it interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this every day of the week.
And as always,
thank you for watching.